oh my goodness look at this how did I
miss this
the Gordon greeted Peter Frampton with
Pritz on the walls oh wow what was the
last time you played the guard and in
the arena did you see her welcome back
son I did I can't believe it look at
that
Frampton first played here in 1970 with
his former band humble pie and still
remembers waiting with drummer Jerry
Shirley to go on I just put out a big
huge Accord guitar and it just went he
would return to the arena repeatedly in
the 70s after the blockbuster success of
Frampton Comes Alive which spent 10
weeks at number one on Friday though
Frampton came back to say farewell in
February on CBS this morning Saturday
Frampton revealed he has a degenerative
muscular disease IBM inclusion body
myositis which is what I have inclusion
body myositis is a rare and incurable
inflammatory condition which causes
muscles to weaken slowly what exactly
have you felt going upstairs and
downstairs is the hardest thing for me
I'm going to have to get a cane and then
the other thing I noticed I can't put
things up over my head
Frampton was diagnosed about four years
ago after an incident on stage and I
fell over
was that a suggestion to you that song
was happening yes I started thinking
what's going on you know so then two
weeks later I fall again on stage so
that's you back in the day so the singer
announced this tour would be his last
how are you feeling physically I feel
good I feel it coming into the fingers
it's coming down my arm but but so far
it hasn't really affected my playing so
I'm thankful for that
yeah
taking the stage at Madison Square
Garden as he has at other arenas
Frampton said he noticed a different
feeling in the room what is that feeling
it's a feeling of love from the audience
they just don't want me to leave yeah
it's awesome
you know they've been my fans out
awesome on the road he's met other IBM
sufferers like a man who came up to him
at a show to thank him then he said I
went to all these doctors I didn't know
what I had they didn't know what I had
and then I turned on the TV and watched
you and Anthony talking and he said you
diagnosed me Wow Wow
so there's people out there that we
really thank you that we really helped
Frampton will conclude his farewell tour
next month near San Francisco where he
recorded Frampton Comes Alive so it's
it's completing the circle yeah you know
wonderfully are you looking forward to
that no I try not to think about this
thing coming to an end yeah
Friday night he took his final bow at
the garden I won't say goodbye and left
the stage he first set foot on almost
half a century ago he said you didn't
want to say goodbye no i-i've not said
goodbye anyway I've just wait because
you never know
[Music]